[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
is
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you do it i don't want nobody
is
[Music]
good morning
how are you
good
morning more days
all right do we have any preliminary
matters at this time
okay sure you want to come forward
okay thank you
so
um
all right good morning ladies and
gentlemen all right
all right your next witness
uh we call dr richard gilbert
dr gilbert
do you sell my swear or affirm to
testify truthfully in this case in a
penalty of law
good morning good morning
good morning dr gilbert good morning
would you please state your name for the
record richard stephen gilbert
and what is your occupation
i am an orthopedic surgeon and i have a
subspecialty training in surgery of the
hand and upper extremity
gilroy where do you work currently
i currently work in new york and long
island at northwell health
and you mentioned you have a specialty
can you tell us a little bit more about
what your specialty is
so after medical school i trained in
orthopedic surgery and i did an
orthopedic surgery residency
and for a year thereafter i did a hand
and upper extremity surgery resin
fellowship
and so my my practice for the past 22
years has been limited to surgery of the
hand wrist and elbow
and i think you may have
gotten ahead of me there but how long
have you been practicing 22 years okay
what percentage of your practice over
the past 22 years has involved surgery
approximately one-third of my practice
okay
and other than that one-third that
involves surgery what does the rest of
your practice entail
the rest of my practice entails
some academic work but mostly
seeing patients in the office seeing
them either pre or post-operatively a
large portion of hand surgeons
treat patients non-operatively
in terms of the surgeries that you do
can you describe for us
the types of surgeries that you will
perform
so again i i limit my practice to hand
wrist and elbow i would say
approximately 75 or so if my practice is
limited to the hand itself
and this really varies from anything
from
conditions like carpal tunnel syndrome
to tendonitis to injuries such as
amputations fractures
sharp lacerations etc
over the course of your 22 years of
practice
how many surgeries would you estimate
you've performed
i performed about three to four hundred
surgeries a year so a rough estimate
would be approximately
10 000
maybe a little less
where are you currently licensed
in new york
and how long have you been licensed in
new york
i've been licensed in new york since
1994. so that would be
28 years
and do you have any certifications
yes
and can you tell us about those
i am
board certified by the american board of
orthopedic surgery and i have a
certificate of added qualifications and
surgery of the hand from the american
society for surgery of the hand
when did you receive your board
certification
2002
and can you describe for us what current
positions you hold
i am currently a an assistant professor
of orthopedic surgery at northwell
health
and i'm also the president-elect of the
new york society for surgery of the
hands
in what professional organizations are
you a member
i'm a member of uh multiple orthopedic
organizations including the
american board of orthopedic surgery the
american association of orthopedic
surgery and
the american society for surgery with
the hand as well as the
new york society for surgery of the hand
have you published any articles in your
field yes i have
have you testified as an expert before
yes i have
can you ballpark for us how many times
uh certainly less than 10 over the past
22 years
your honor at this time we'd like to
offer dr gilbert as an expert in the
field of orthopedic surgery specializing
in the hand any objection no objection
ron so moved
so dr gilbert
what work were you asked to do in
connection with this case
so i was asked to review
medical records radiographs pictures
as well as
testimonies and depositions related to
mr duff's finger injury
okay
and
to your understanding
what is mr depp's explanation of how his
finger was injured
he describes that he was in australia
and his right hand was over the side of
a bar
when a
vodka bottle was thrown at his hand
injuring his right middle finger
and he describes that the vodka bottle
exploded
are you aware of other explanations for
that injury
uh there have been multiple other
explanations uh but i think the the one
that was was brought out was by miss
heard who
uh
believed that mr depp was holding a
landline and have anger was punching it
against the wall and this resulted in
his right middle finger injury okay
based on your review of the
medical records um
and other documents in connection with
mr depp's finger injury
how would you describe the nature of the
injury to mr duff's finger
well the nature of the injury was
he had what we described as a community
fracture of the distal phalanx meaning
there was a fracture of the tip of the
finger and commodity meaning that there
are multiple pieces
so this is some type of blunt force with
a high mechanism of injury he also
sustained
loss of the tissue along what's called
the ulnar side of the finger towards the
little finger
and this
appeared
based upon my review of the pictures to
be some type of sharp laceration because
it represented a clean
edges of the wound
let me take a look at plaintiff's
exhibit 60
and pull up to go and go to page three
and dr gilbert are you familiar with
this
document
yes
and what is it
so these are two
radiographs x-rays of mr depp's fingers
finger his middle finger okay um
sorry just to stop you but uh your honor
may we publish this to the jury as a
demonstrative any objection
all right we'll identify it as 60 page 3
and
publish to the jury
and dr gilbert sorry sorry to cut you
off there can you can you just tell tell
the jury um
what we're looking at here
two x-rays of uh mr depp's right middle
finger after the injury
and towards the tip of the finger
there's a fracture
again what i described as a comedy root
fracture meaning there are multiple
pieces at the tip there's also a
transverse component to the fracture
closer to the joint
in your view what types of mechanisms
can cause this sort of injury
so this is a
mechanism injury that has high velocity
or force generally a crush type injury
a simple fall would not result in a
comet fracture such as as seen in these
x-rays
and we're using the term counter
fracture can we just define that quickly
for us so again common needed and it's
not particular to a finger can
is a medical term for a fracture that
has multiple fragments
in your opinion could this injury have
been sustained in the manner mr depp
described
i do believe so
and how might that work
how might a throne vodka bottle produce
an injury like this so vodka bottle
which is a hard object would have
crushed the tip of the finger resulting
in the common duty fracture
and in addition as the vodka bottle
broke
the
glass would have
lacerated the finger resulting in the
soft tissue loss that was also seen with
this injury
what's your assessment of
the description of the cause of the
injury offered by ms heard
i think that's highly unlikely
and
why is that
because one
[Music]
in general when an injury is caused by
punching against a
wall or a hard object
it is extremely rare to see an injury to
the tips of the fingers which is seen
with mr depp's injury generally you're
holding something with a fist
and that in general leads to injuries
most commonly of the knuckles here
or fractures of the metacarpals we call
these boxer fractures
second most common after those would be
injuries to these but as you can see if
you're holding something and make
hitting against something it is very
unlikely that the tips of the fingers
will be injured
in addition
just
taking into account the radiographs and
the pictures of the injury
i would not believe that a blunt force
solely of blunt force against a wall
would result in the soft tissue loss
what other injuries if any would you
expect to see
on mr depp's hand uh if the injury had
occurred as ms heard described so
if you would have
if that were the cause of the injury you
would certainly that would be endorsely
directed so this is the doors on the
back of the hand
as opposed to the palmer side so if
you're punching against something you
would certainly expect an injury to the
nail bed and those are always seen in
those type of injuries if there is an
injury to the tip of the finger which
again i said is rare so you would see
either a loss of the nail or blood
underneath the nail called the subungual
hematoma
in your review of the medical records
did you see any sign of anything like
that none whatsoever
in your view is the injury
can you tell can you explain to us
exactly why you think the injury um
is consistent with mr depp's description
well again
his hand he describes his hand being
held
over a marble bar which is a firm
uh
something firm
on yielding and the bottle hit against
the finger
so basically the fingers crushed
resulting in again what i described as a
common neutral fracture
and as mr depp described the bottle
exploded so
it's certainly reasonable that the the
glass that exploded as well
led to the soft tissue loss along the
ulnar aspect of this finger
now did you observe the testimony of dr
uh richard moore
yes i did
and he testified about mr depp's finger
injury as well correct
did you agree with dr moore's testimony
certain parts of his testimony i did yes
but not all of it
focusing on the parts that you well
first of all why don't you tell us what
you agree on
well he agreed in terms of his
interpretation of of the x-rays
saying that
he had a comedy to fracture and this was
a
some type of high force injury
okay
what did you disagree with
well he disagreed uh with several things
that he said he first said that
he does not believe that the mechanism
of injury could be
as described by mr depp
holding the hand
on the side of a
marble
bar
uh because he said it was all a palmer
injury and
there was a palmer component to the
injury but i'm talking about the soft
tissue loss but there's also a dorsal
meaning the back of the finger
so the soft tissue loss was actually if
you
looked at the pictures which were shown
uh when dr moore
testified
the injury goes like this so it's it's
an angled or an oblique type injury
and there's no way that anybody could
determine whether or not it was a palmar
directive force meaning from the palm
side or dorsally directive force
but certainly either plausible
okay
anything else come to mind that you
disagreed with
well he also uh
described that
this was
definite well he thought that this was a
pinching or what he described as an
avulsion type injury
and that's referring to the soft tissue
loss
lost
that's certainly possible but if you
look at the pictures that were shown
when he testified
the laceration looked fairly clean there
were clean edges it was not jagged and
generally when you have an avulsion or a
pinch type injury you see a very
irregular border to the skin
it's pinched off you can imagine as
opposed to something that's cleaner that
would be lacerated by let's just say a
piece of glass or a knife or whatever
and that's more consistent with the
pictures of mr depp's injury
and we we're using the term soft tissue
loss and just to make sure we're on the
same page can you just tell very quickly
what you're referring to there right so
so he there were two two components of
this injury one the fracture of the bone
and two he had loss of
the the soft tissues um so that the bone
was exposed
so that amputated part that was found at
the bar
now you were saying that dr moore
testified that this was an avulsion
and
meaning a pinching injury right correct
why do you believe it's more likely that
it was a laceration
well again i i
in general a pinch-type injury results
in
one much more damage to the remaining
tissue but the remaining tissue is
usually very irregular the borders are
jagged
and that's not what was depicted in the
pictures
dr moore also testified that he thought
a vodka bottle might not have sufficient
force to cause the injury here
is that your understanding of his
testimony
correct
what's your response to that
um i certainly believe that a
vodka bottle that was thrown from a
distance
against a hand that was resting on the
marble bore or is more than sufficient
forced to result in this fracture and
soft tissue loss
now in in looking at the medical records
and the pictures of mr depp's hand
what was the condition of his nail
there was no injury to the nail
and other than what you've already told
us how does that factor into your
analysis if at all the fact that there
was no injury to the nail
well it it
makes it highly unlikely that the
mechanism of injury described by mis
heard
resulted in this injury because you
really
would always see an injury to the nail
and or nail bed
do you have any opinion regarding the
direction of the injury
well
it's certainly
based upon the soft tissue loss it's an
angled injury or what we call a
medically an oblique injury because the
soft tissue loss is at an angle
he lost some of the tissue on the back
of the finger as well as the palm side
primarily along the palm side but other
than that
you can't make any assumptions
unless you saw a videotape of this
injury
nobody could tell you definitively what
the direction of the injury was
dr murr also commented on the absence of
fragments of broken glass in mr depp's
injury
do you remember that yes i do
and
how does the absence of glass fragments
factor into your analysis
i it really doesn't um i've seen
hundreds if not
probably at least 500 or more glass
injuries and
i would say probably the majority you
don't see glass in in these injuries
it is much more common to see
glass embedded in the wounds when you're
talking about very fine glass so if
to say a wine glass would explode or
something of that nature where you get
little tiny shards
but in general when you have thick glass
such as you see in a bottle or
or a pane of glass you generally don't
see because they
break into bigger pieces and you
generally don't see the glass but um
you certainly can but it's not
surprising that you don't
can you definitively state how this
injury occurred
no i nobody can definitively state
okay
no further questions all right
cross-examination
thank you your honor
good morning dr gilbert good morning
now you're you're being paid a thousand
dollars an hour for your work on this
case correct correct
and you agree just to sum up
how mr moniz finished you agree that
that the finger injury could be could
have been caused by any number of things
right
yes and you're not offering an expert
opinion on what you believe caused the
finger injury
correct
correct
and you're aware
you said
a few times
miss heard's account or misheard's
explanation
right you remember saying that yes
you're actually aware that that amber
has
said she didn't doesn't know how he lost
his finger you're aware of that right
yes
so when you were just talking about miss
herd's account or mr's explanation
you're where she's she's never actually
given an explanation for how she thinks
he lost his finger
correct
no
yes
you're aware that miss heard testified
and this is from your deposition you're
you're aware that she testified she
doesn't know how he got his fingertip
chopped off you're aware of that right
asking dancer
no i'm not i reviewed the records
and in
one of the testimonies that i
depositions that i reviewed um it was
described that um
that
potentially it was lost uh when he was
punching against the wall with the phone
and and on that
the last point there i think we agree
miss hertz testified in this trial and
previously that she saw him smash a
phone to smithereens a wall thumb you'd
agree with that correct correct but she
doesn't know if that was what caused him
to lose his finger
you agree with that correct
i i
agree i cannot speak for her but yes
okay
may i approach your honor yes sir
thank you
dr gilbert um you gave a deposition in
this case on march 17th correct correct
you were under oath in that deposition
you swore to tell the truth correct
correct okay if you could turn to page
61 please
you see there are four four pages per
page of paper
it's on page 16 of the document
okay okay line nine
um you're asked a question and then
amber's response to that question that's
the line nine can you read that please
answer
i do not know
i did not see his finger go off
question and dr gilbert are you aware
that amber did not see mr depp's finger
go off
answer i mean i'm aware that well i'm
aware from reading
i am from reading this i'm aware of the
mechanism that she claimed would cause
the finger injury question but have you
read anything so far that indicates she
doesn't know how the finger injury
happened answer so far from what i'm
reading here yes did i read that right
yes and
you've heard no testimony in this trial
from misheard that the finger injury was
definitively caused by the phone so that
she doesn't know correct correct and
you'd agree that the fingernail was
uninjured you said that right correct
and the nail bed was uninjured correct
correct
but the area under the fingernail in the
pulp of the finger that's where the
injury took place right
it was not isolated to the pulp no but
it didn't injure the fingernail that's
correct
and under mr depp's
alleged theory
amber threw a vodka bottle at him from
10 feet away or so right correct and you
testified you have no way to determine
the angle that the bottle was coming
from
correct but she threw it on a downward
trajectory correct she didn't there's no
allegation you've never read anything
that she somehow underhanded it so it
came up to his finger right correct and
there's no way to tell as you testified
what exact direction it came from right
correct and the glass exploded but
you've already testified there was no
glass in the wound right
correct you haven't read any record of
that in any medical records correct
correct you also haven't read anything
about there being cuts on the rest of
his hand right correct and there was no
glass found anywhere on the rest of his
hand correct correct no bruising or
injury on any other part of his hand
other than the tip of his middle finger
correct
and somehow
under mr depp's theory that bottle hit
the bar
and his fingers but didn't damage the
fingernail while it amputated the area
under the nail
correct correct
and
your explanation of that
is that you believe
that
his hand must have moved at some point
during the force of the injury isn't
that correct no i said it could have but
i i did not say that it did no you you
you believe that it did don't you
i said that it likely did but i was not
there and i don't have videotape of the
injury so i can't determine that
definitively okay well
let's turn to page 25 of your deposition
please on page seven
sorry page page 25 and 26 so it's page
seven of the doc okay sorry if i was
unclear on that no problem
i'm there okay
um line 18
question and to be clear
by quote sitting in that position you
mean hand down palmer side down
answer that's what he claimed i mean
according to the history yes
question and would it matter if mr
depp's hand was palmer side down answer
not really because it really and i
discussed this it really just depends
upon the angle at which the injury
occurred and as well you can't determine
if his hand had moved at some point
during the force of the injury
which i believe it probably did
which i didn't get into in my note here
but
question and why do you believe that
have you read anything in any of the
materials to suggest that
answer
no
just that if it completely hit on the
back of the finger then he would have
had a nail bed injury which he did not
did i read that right correct that was
testimony you gave under oath a month or
two ago right correct
so even though you have never read
anything that suggests mr depp's hand
moved
his hand moving is the only way
that you can fit your testimony
into what mr depp wants you to testify
to about how the injury occurred isn't
it no that's incorrect okay that's what
you testify to that if if his hand
hadn't moved that there would be a nail
bed injury correct that is incorrect
that's not what i testified
dr gilbert there's another explanation
for how mr depp somehow suffered an
injury that didn't injure his nail one
bit but injured underneath the nail and
that explanation is that it didn't
happen how mr depp says it did
correct i cannot make that assumption
nor can you
no further questions all right redirect
dr gilbert just very
briefly the absence of other cuts on mr
depp's hand
how do you factor that into your
analysis
you certainly can see an isolated finger
injury with any type of injury and i
would say
any other host of mechanisms of injuries
you'd more likely see other so again if
you're i'm just using this as an example
if you're punching against a wall you
would more likely see multiple injuries
to multiple fingers it really just
depends upon how the bottle or
how the
the
mechanism of the injury
impacted the hand at that point in time
miss hurt's counsel made a point of
emphasizing that there were no bruises
or other injuries on the hand right
correct
and
how does that fact uh affect your
analysis if at all
well it
it doesn't discount anything but it
certainly makes
uh other
potential
causes of injury more unlikely meaning
punching against the wall or getting the
hand slammed in a door or something like
that
and your
discussion of ms heard's explanation
of the
alternative cause of the injury
was that based on anything other than
misheard statements
no
no further questions all right thank you
doctor you can have a seat in the
courtroom or you're free to go thank you
oh you can just leave it there that's
fine thank you sir thank you
all right
your next witness
playing defroster on it all right plenty
of rest the rebuttal case sorry
defended counter plaintiff rebuttal case
sure
all right rebuttal
evidence yes
mr murphy we call mr julian acker all
right
mr ackerd
he has to be sworn
in this case the penalty of law
good morning good morning can you please
state your name
julian eckert
and can you please describe your
educational background following high
school i have a bachelor of science in
computer science from the university of
virginia
what is your profession
i am a computer forensics investigator
where are you employed
i work for a company called eye
discovery solutions or ids
and what is your title
i'm a managing director at that company
what services does ids perform
ids provides
consulting expert testimony forensic
analysis data analysis electronic data
review and production services all to
the business and legal community
what if any of those services performed
by ids have you performed i perform all
of those services
how many years of experience do you have
in computer forensics investigation i've
worked in the industry for 20 years
can you please describe that experience
to the jury
i have experience creating and
implementing data preservation and
collection strategies
doing data collections in a forensically
sound manner extracting data from
collections as well as analysis and
metadata analysis of the evidence that i
extract
you mentioned collecting data from
forensic collections
what material are you forensically
imaging
this would be any type of material that
stores digital evidence an iphone an
ipad a tablet a
laptop a cloud account your gmail
account anything that has digital
evidence
have you published in your areas of
expertise
yes i've published on data preservation
and collection and analysis strategies
have you ever given any trainings or
presentations to other individuals in
the e-discovery area
yes i have i do trainings and
presentations to lawyers through
continuous learning education
what if any professional certifications
do you have
i have a gf gcfe that's the gx certified
forensic examiner
certification and what were the
requirements of obtaining that
certification
to obtain that certification you need a
minimum number of hours in the field as
well as you need to pass a test with a
certain degree of
a certain percentage of passing
do you belong to any professional
organizations
i do i'm a member of a conference called
the sedona conference it's a conference
that
is a group of
legal professionals judges and
technologists and we discuss the
intersection of law and technology and
technology issues in the legal community
have you previously served as an expert
witness
yes i have
and when did you first serve as an
expert witness
i believe that would have been around
2009 was the first time i served
have you previously been qualified as an
expert witness in the field of computer
forensics
yes i have i've been qualified probably
a half dozen to a dozen times in both
federal and state court including this
court right here
and has a court ever declined to qualify
you as an expert witness
no they have not your honor i offer
julian acker is an expert in the field
of computer forensics
no objection all right so boot could you
spell your last name for me mr hackert
a-c-k-e-r-t
thank you so much sir
um mr acker what is forensic imaging
forensic imaging is the process of
capturing the data on a digital device
in a forensically sound manner
and how is a forensic copy created
using specialized software that's
available to forensic investigators
we're able to collect the data from
devices and that software may vary
depending on the device like a phone or
a laptop
what type of information does a forensic
image collect
it's meant to really collect everything
on the device so for example on a laptop
it's going to collect your documents
your emails your photographs your
documents like excel spreadsheets pdf
files any applications that you ran
the the history of what you've opened or
looked at on the laptop as well as all
of the metadata for these different
types of electronically stored
information files
and does any other information accompany
that information that's collected
typically with a forensic image you're
also going to get log files log files
are files that help you validate the
forensic image and verify that it was a
forensically sound data collection and
how do log files enable you to do that
log files list information within the
files sometimes they're even embedded
within the images themselves but they
provide verification information that
allows you to authenticate the image and
the data on the image
what is the purpose of creating a
forensic image of devices or data
in order to extract and analyze data
forensically for the chords you need to
create a forensic image of the data
first and gather the forensic and gather
the data from the forensic image
and what if any specific types of data
are collected in that image and
extraction
it's going to be any type of data that
comes from the image whether you're
extracting photographs or documents or
spreadsheets or anything of that nature
do you recall mr newmeister mentioning
the term hashing yesterday i do what is
that
hashing is essentially the a digital
fingerprint of a file it's a evaluation
of the binary ones and zeros or how the
file is stored on a hard drive and it
examines the ones and zeros in a manner
that gives every file a digital
fingerprint essentially and identifies
the uniqueness of the file
and what if any applicability does
hashing have to the visual appearance of
data
hashing has nothing to do with the
visual appearance
for example if i had a word document
that i
printed and then saved therefore i
haven't visually changed the word
document the metadata of that word
document indicating that i printed it
would be different and therefore that
word document would not hash to the
version that i that i use before
printing
can you give any examples of digital
photographs that visually appear the
same not hashing
i believe mr newmeister included three
of those in his demonstratives yesterday
three side-by-side photographs that
looked visually the same but did not
hash
it made sense that they wouldn't hash
each of them had different file sizes
and a file size can change for a
photograph depending on what you do with
the photograph so for example maybe you
want to take that photograph and email
it to somebody and on your phone
you choose to use a small medium or
large or different size of the
photograph on your email when you send
that email with that photograph you
changed the hash value because you've
changed the ones and zeros because
you've changed the size of the
photograph
and
what if anything do you recall from mr
newmeister's testimony regarding photos3
mr newmeister was concerned about a
particular metadata field exif metadata
which there's two types of metadata for
files there's the embedded metadata
which is what we're discussing here the
exif metadata and external metadata and
mr newmeister was concerned with
embedded metadata within the file that
indicated that the software version that
the file last ran through was photos
what is photos 3.0
photos is actually the software
application that's built into the apple
macintosh operating system for laptops
this is the application that launches by
default when you're on an apple computer
and use photos
what are the capabilities of photos 3.0
there's multiple capabilities for it you
can for example create an album with it
and put multiple photos within an album
you can
organize or sort your photos by date and
time taken or place you can also use
that to edit photos
you mentioned metadata earlier what is
that
metadata is information about a file for
example with a document it could be when
was the document created or last saved
or who saved it who is the author of the
document for photographs metadata
includes information that you've seen on
demonstratives before including
including when was the image taken what
kind of phone took the image what
software was originally used for that
image
any type of information inside the
photograph the exif data that you've
heard is metadata
did you form any opinions in response to
mr newmeister's testimony regarding
photos 3.0 appearing in a software exif
metadata field yes i did and what are
those
my opinion is that
for each of the photos that he
identified for all but one in his
demonstrative i actually found the
equivalent original photo that did not
have photos in the xf metadata in other
words those are the photos that he was
indicated he would have expected to see
the ios or the phone software version on
those photos
how do you know it is an original
version of the photograph this is this
is a little bit dependent on the apple
ecosystem amber uses apple devices and
those devices by definition of how apple
works synchronize your information from
device to device so for example if you
take a photo on your phone you see that
same photo on your tablet or your ipad
or your icloud account or even your
macbook and that's all because of user
experience apple wants you to be able to
see and visually have the same
experience on all your devices so the
photo that was originally taken
traverses or gets synchronized to other
devices by design of apple and that
synchronization process does not affect
the metadata that we're talking about
here which is the embedded metadata
when you say that a version of ios
software was listed in the software exit
metadata field what does that mean
that means that the photo was not saved
using the photos application
and what if any data sets did you use to
come to that conclusion
i used all of the data sets that i
collected or were collected for amber
including mobile devices tablets laptops
etc
michelle can you please pull up
defendants exhibit 1671
do you recognize this chart mr eckert
i do
what is it
without without yet saying what it the
contents just generally what is it uh
this is a chart i created as part of my
report
your honor permission to publish
defendant 671 is a demonstrative
any objection no objection all right
it'll be published as a democrat
um mr acker can you please describe in
more detail what the information in this
chart is michelle can you just stay at
the top for a quick second
a little further up
great thank you
this chart represents for each of the
items in newmeister's report which his
demonstrative was based on the page
number of uh the item on his report and
the id the items that i found on ms
herd's devices that did not indicate the
software
metadata fields showing
photos rather they indicated that they
were the original software metadata
field of ios
and do you see the second column titled
new meister report date captured
yes i do what does the information in
that column mean
uh this is the date time metadata of the
particular photo on new meister's report
so for example uh the first row 23 the
date time captured or the date captured
is december 16th 2015.
uh the second row 24 you see that the
date time is may 21st 2016.
third row may 21st 2016
fourth row may 21st 2016. you just
scroll to the next page please michelle
uh please continue for the the items on
this page uh the top row of this page
the one that came from newmeister's
report page 30 shows december 16 2016
and then finally 32 shows march 23rd
2013.
do you see
uh can you scroll back to the top please
michelle do you see the
um
all the way at the top i'm sorry the
right hand column of this chart yes i do
and where it says device id and file
name yes can you please explain what the
information in that column means for
each of the items identified from mr
newmeister's demonstrative
so these are the evidence ids and
evidence id is the id value i give to a
particular piece of data that i collect
for example a phone or a laptop and the
matching file name found on that
evidence id that indicated the original
version of the same photograph that
newmeister identified that did not show
photos in the software metadata and
rather showed the ios version in the
metadata
and what do the little
a's followed by numbers back up what
does that mean
those are evidence ids anything with an
a number is the evidence id of an actual
device collected anything that starts
with a backup and follows by another
number is an itunes backup
so what if any what
items in this right-hand column um
based on the
coding you have here are itunes backups
uh only the ones that start with the
word backup even the ones that start
with an a number are actually an itunes
or an ios backup in icloud so your phone
can actually be backed up to icloud and
those are coming from an ios backup and
icloud everything else is coming from an
actual physical device
um can you just take this down for a
second michelle and pull up 1675 please
defend in 1675.
and um
do you recognize this chart mr eckert
yes i do without yet getting into the
contents can you please describe
generally what it is
this is a chart that i prepared as a
summary of my findings
um permission to publish defendant 1675
is a demonstrative your honor any
objection no objection all right 1675 we
publish this demonstration
can you please describe in more detail
what the three columns you can see in
this chart represent
sure this starts to give some detail
about the particular evidence id so for
example a001 was an iphone x of ambers
that was collected a002 was an ipad of
amber's collected uh a 10 i'm sorry a11
12 and 13 slightly down are three
different laptops that were collected
for amber
and do you see the ids evidence number
column
yes i do
do you see the source type column yes i
do in the source details column yes i do
can you please describe what those
columns mean uh generally the idn's
evidence number is the evidence number
that we assigned to a particular piece
of evidence and the type and details
come from a description of that type of
evidence based upon the collection set
and michelle can you please do a side by
side of 1675 and 1671
thank you um
so mr actor can you please describe the
relationship between these two
demonstrative exhibits
certainly uh if you look at 1671 the one
on the left you can see in the fourth
column uh the different evidence ids
where i identified the original versions
of those same pictures that mr
newmeister had
specifically identified and the sources
of where they were identified so if you
look at the first one for example the uh
the picture new meister referenced on
page 24
or i guess that's the second one there
are
equivalent versions or original versions
of those that do not show the software
xf metadata field of photos rather it
shows the original ios version on a01
which was amber heard's iphone x
a002 which is amber heard's ipad pro
scrolling on down through there you see
it on a011 which is amber heard's
laptop same with a0 12 and 13.
you can see this again with the next row
that's visible at the very top uh
newmeister identified a photograph on
page 30
taken on december 16 2015 and he was
concerned about the
exif metadata of that showing the
software version of photos the original
versions of those were found again on
a01 that's her iphone x a002 her ipad
and it's not surprising to me that i
found all these on all the devices
because that's how the apple ecosystem
works it replicates your pictures or
synchronizes your pictures across your
devices when you take them
um mr acker you can take this dumb shell
do you recall mr newmeister's testimony
regarding what he claims of exif
metadata modification
yes i do this is a completely
hypothetical scenario mr newmeister
never specified any pictures with
specificity that were had excess
metadata modification and it's a
hypothetical in my opinion
um mr acker did you form any overall
conclusions in this case
yes i did and what were those
the images that uh were created in this
case were included log files that
allowed me to validate and verify the
evidence collected i validated and
verified the log files of the
evidence for which i found mr
newmeister's original photos that he had
concerns about specifically the ones
that had ios and the software metadata
field
uh i validated that those came from
devices that had uh
had been had log files that were
validated by me in other words they came
from original evidence files and in in
most instances they came from more than
one file
um
mr acker the opinions you have testified
to testify to today made to a reasonable
degree of forensic certainty yes they
are
no further questions your honor all
right cross-examination sir
thank you your honor good morning sir
good morning
you've worked with opposing counsel's
law firm
approximately 20 times before
give or take yes
for more than a dozen years
those 20 probably would have spread out
been spread out over more than a dozen
years okay
as you sit here today
you cannot testify
that all of the photographs produced by
miss heard
are authentic originals
correct no i can testify to the ones
that mr newmeister identified with
specificity right but there were
thousands of photographs
provided that mr neumeyer didn't testify
about right
i have no opinions on any photographs
that the opposing expert has no opinions
on
my question to you though is
as you sit here today
can you testify that all the photographs
produced by miss heard are authentic
originals
as i sit here today i cannot open the
photographs that have not been presented
to me that are not authentic originals
you'll agree with me that in some
instances
misheard produced multiple versions of
the same photograph right
yes
yeah you just talked about it right
yes
and you'll agree with me
that the xf data of some of the photos
produced by ms heard
reflect the use of a photo editing
application
no
no
i'll agree that they show the use of the
photos application which is a sorting
and editing application
okay so you what what you
were equivalent with is that it will
both sort and edit
that is correct okay
are you prepared to swear under oath
that each and every photograph provided
by ms heard
and entered into evidence in this court
is an authentic original
based on the metadata that i have
reviewed of the specific photographs i
have reviewed i can confirm that those
are authentic original photographs for
the ones that mr newmeister identified i
identified photos that were authentic
originals no i'm asking a broader
question that
there were multiple photographs that
mishad provided that were entered into
evidence in this court
are you testifying
that those are each authentic originals
i have no uh testimony or opinion on
those because nobody's provided me
opinion that they're not
okay
mr gibson will you pull up
defendants exhibit 712
and defendants
713 next to one another your honor these
have already been admitted and i ask
that we publish it to the jury okay
they're admitted we can publish
can you see this sir
yes i can
you'll agree with me that those are
different pictures
visually they look different to me yes
all right
we can take that down
mr gibson can you
pull up plaintiff's exhibit
1308
this has not been admitted your honor
and i'm and i propose to use it as a
demonstrative
any objection not as a demonstrative
your honor all right
be identified and publish the jury as a
democrat
any objection to entering it into
evidence
i would object it's cumulative your
honor um
actually no no no objection no objection
alright it's in evidence then
1308 is in evidence
mr gibson can you blow up the time
date and file name
sir you just
agreed with me
that those two photos
are different photos
correct
i agree that they were visually
different yes right so they are two
visually different photos
that were created at the exact same
hour
the exact same minute
the exact same second
as each other correct
that's what the daytime metadata shows
yes
and the metadata shows something else
too
they have the exact same file name don't
they sir
yes but that's not embedded metadata
right
how would you have this jury decide
which one is real
i think he would need to look at the
software metadata field which i haven't
looked at i don't recall if i looked at
for this particular field but i think
that's what even mr newmeister said that
you need to look at the software
metadata field
but we have two
photographs entered into evidence in
this court
that had the same identifying
information
but in your view
look visually different correct
i don't agree that they have the same
identifying information i'm not i don't
see a software metadata field here
the identifying information includes
them the hour minute and second they
were taken
this picture were taken
i see that
no further questions all right and just
for the record since we already have 7
12 and 7 13 and evidence
as redacted now this will be 7 12 and 7
13 a so 7 12 a and 7 12 13 a are now in
evidence just to keep the record clean
okay
all right redirect um mr acker you just
mentioned embedded metadata what is that
embedded metadata is metadata inside a
file oh i talked earlier about the date
printed of a word document that's
embedded into the file and that
traverses with the file wherever it goes
and based on all of the photo metadata
you have reviewed do you have any reason
to question the forensic authenticity of
any photos mr newmeister testified to
which you were responding to
can you repeat that question please
based on all of the photo metadata you
have reviewed based on the photos mr
newmeister testified to do you have any
reason to question the forensic
authenticity of those photos i do not
following your cross-examination mr
eckert have any of your opinions in this
matter changed they have not and is it
still your testimony that the opinions
you testified to do today are made with
a reasonable degree of forensic
certainty
yes no further questions all right thank
you sir you can have a seat in the
courtroom where you're free to go
all right did you want to approach just
for a moment
all right your next witness
your honor we would like to call dr don
hughes to the story dr hughes
thank you doctor just remind that you're
still under oath okay man thank you
[Music]
and could you please just remind the
jury who you are again
sure i'm a clinical and forensic
psychologist i am board certified in
forensic psychology i am the
president-elect of the trauma division
of the american psychological
association
and i evaluated amber heard over six
visits for approximately 29 hours okay
and why are you here today
to offer a rebuttal testimony to shannon
curry's testimony of yesterday okay now
dr curry said you used improper methods
would you agree with that
no i would not why please explain
i as i testified to you all several
weeks ago i used a standard forensic
procedure that is well established in
our field it is a multi-method
multi-hypothesis driven
procedure where you're looking at a
variety of different details and tests
and external data to arrive at an
opinion and you're looking at the
consistency across that data
there are three sort of sets of of tests
that we use as forensic psychologists
and i think that's where it seems that
dr curry seems confused we have forensic
assessment instruments those are
instruments that are
very neatly tied to a legal criteria
those are most notably done in a
criminal court for competency if someone
has competencies stand trial we have
very clear measures that can track that
legal criteria
the next level are forensically relevant
instruments and those instruments are
not linked to a specific legal criteria
but they do have information that's
germane to that finding and that can be
an example of a risk assessment measure
and a malingering measure so the
malingering measure was that i utilized
was the mfast and that was the only
lingering measure in this case
the third category are clinical
assessment instruments and those are
instruments that are validated and well
researched and used in the clinical
realm as we understand people's
symptomatology and diagnostic
and functional capacities those are
things like
the mmpi the pai the caps the tsi
because they are clinically relevant and
they still give us very valuable
information to individuals who are
involved in a court case and the reason
that we do that and we use these
clinical measures is because the
majority of the people that we see are
in a clinical realm they're not in a
courtroom um so they're well validated
and well-researched methods
what we also do is use a very different
types of tests within that category we
use some checklists some face valid
checklists we use some tests that are
those broadband personality inventories
we use structured clinical interviews
and then we look for the consistency
across those data points and when we use
different types of tests it gives us
information about the individual how
they go about these tests in these
different modalities
now
dr curry seemed to suggest that that
amber heard
tested the most extreme category in all
of these different tests is that
accurate
compound
that is not accurate they were not on
the checklist i mean people sometimes do
they go all the time this happens to me
all the time frequently and that is not
how she endorsed these tests she
endorsed them in a very moderate way in
a very nuanced way describing her
symptoms
that i determined was accurate and
reliable
dr curry also suggested that
amber hurd was uh tested very very high
98 percentile i think i'm malingering
and feigning
could you speak to that please sure so
i mean she said a lot of things so let's
go through those tests the first was the
pai and that's that other
objection non-responsive
i think it's very responsive it's
sustainable i'll do okay could you tell
the jury about the pai test that dr kirk
yes so
yes thank you so that's the broadband
measure that has validity scales built
into it that gives us indications about
how the individual goes about the test i
told you last time that there was no
evidence of malingering or exaggeration
or feigning on that test what dr curry
was talking about was this
tendency to put your best foot forward
to minimize faults on this pai
that scale was
right at the cusp and then there are two
other measures that we look at that to
say you know is this enough for an
elevation for me to consider that as a
serious response distortion of which dr
curry was saying and it was not
what was relevant on this test was there
were elevations on anxiety on effective
anxiety meaning anxiety tension worry
on traumatic stress
on
hyperactivity
and on affective instability those were
the four scales that were elevated on
this test the borderline scale was not
elevated on this test and this test
objection your honor
may we approach yes
so dr curry let's move to the tsi too dr
curry testified about your findings on
that did you agree with her testimony
yesterday no again describe why explain
why um what dr curry went back to
which is this 98th percentile which i
told you in the manual all you have to
do is read the manual
it says specifically that we do not use
the percentile ranks for this test that
indicates to me that you know dr curry
does not know the psychometric
properties of this test and then she
then is therefore not qualified to
interpret it um that score the one
that's elevated which is talking about
that percentile rank has a raw score
amber's raw score is a 10. the cut off
score is a 15.
she's nowhere near that level of
exaggerated symptoms where i can't
further
look at that test
secondly there are three scales out of
about maybe there's about 20 a little
more on the tsi that were elevated
intrusive experiences that's when
thoughts and memories of the trauma come
into your mind when you don't want them
defensive avoidance sort of behavioral
ways that we try to push out those
memories and not think about them and
then relational avoidance a way of
having difficulty in interpersonal
relationships those are all trauma-based
symptoms and those were elevated um on
this test
thank you
dr hughes uh the m-fast dr curry
addressed that as well and had
criticisms for your interpretations do
you agree with that no please explain to
them so the mfast as i told you last
time is a measure of malingering it's
the only measure of malingering that was
done in this case dr curry did not
independently administer measure
malingering and there are other ones
that she could have done to augment her
evaluation
um and she kept saying something that m
fast is not for malingered ptsd
that's wrong on a couple levels
people who are going to maligner and
feigned don't only feign one diagnosis
they sometimes talk about all different
symptoms that they have and they
exaggerate and they make themselves seem
much worse than they are so when you're
doing an evaluation you're giving them a
lingering measure to get a sense of how
this person is responding to this
evaluation now what you do is you take
those three tests that i talked to you
about the pai the tsi and the mfast all
with valid validity scales you have
greater confidence in your results and
that is in the literature and that's
literature that dr curry cited in her
report
that bolsters the methodology that i
used that in the study that had the pai
the m-fast and the tsi in the title of
detecting feigned from bonafide ptsd
thank you dr curry also talked about the
danger assessment scale and suggested
that you had inappropriately interpreted
that do you agree that's also incorrect
please describe for the jury which i
told you last time the danger assessment
scale has
statistically validated risk factors for
serious or lethal domestic violence
those risk factors exist whether we go
forward we're sitting with someone in an
acute setting and assessing them right
now or if we look backward and we look
retrospectively about what factors may
have been present in a case that
indicated severity
that instrument is used in what we call
theirs called domestic fatality review
boards those are boards after somebody
has been killed a homicide has occurred
in a domestic situation they look at
these risk factors to see what was there
and what could be done
right dr curry also criticized your
administration of the caps five do you
agree with her criticisms i do not will
you please explain to the jury so the
the caps five as you all have heard
multiple times is a structured clinical
interview
in determining um ptsd according to
dsm-5 criteria um on this measure amber
heard scored in a moderate range she did
not over exaggerate on this test she
could have said
no
mild moderate severe and extreme all of
hers were either twos or ones or zeros
not above that
so she's scoring in the moderate range
which still has functional impairments i
mean we don't want someone to be having
moderate ptsd but that's not an
exaggerated profile or exaggerated
response style of someone who's um
answering an instrument
all right and the last of these dr curry
referred to was the pcl five
do you agree with her criticisms of your
administration and interpretation of
that no so the pcl5 is a checklist of
symptoms of ptsd it is
as she said it is a face validation it
seems it's very clear about how you can
endorse this but what the person has to
do is say how how disturbed am i by
these symptoms and when you have face
valid measures with these other measures
that have the built-in sort of ability
scales you're sort of controlling for
that response bias error you're
controlling for that
individual to sort of over exaggerate
but then what you do with that test
because this is you know we're not just
administering them like robots is you go
and you do a clinical assessment and
that's what i did i took what she wrote
what she endorsed on that test in
january of 2021 and i did a clinical
assessment of those symptoms to see if
they meet criteria for ptsd that is
something we do clinically and i do in
my office all the time and yes she did
meet ptsd from that in january 2021.
thank you
now dr curry said you misinterpreted her
test results do you agree with that
yeah
i agree that i miss into i agree that i
interpreted that she misinterpreted them
okay
and please explain yeah so i am i said
that before i i you know my stance on
the mmpi and how she interpreted it is
i believe wrong and i think objection
your honor
that's the issue we just addressed all
right
i don't if you want to approach
now dr hughes dr curry also testified
that a victim of ptsd has to effectively
be prone and unable to function at all
would you agree with that
objection mistakes the evidence all
right she said they couldn't hike they
couldn't uh move they couldn't function
in any shape way shape or form thank you
um no that is not correct that is often
actually a myth a misconception about
individuals who were struggling with
ptsd or trauma-based disorders and i'm
often called to answer that and speak to
that um you know people who are
struggling with trauma and ptsd are very
strong courageous resilient people even
though that they're struggling they get
up they have to go to work and drop
their kid off at school and go to the
market even though they're struggling
with these symptoms so i often talk
about it as they're sort of walking
around with a 50 pound bag of flour on
their backs just sort of trying to get
through the day where sometimes that
button is going to press play and the
trauma is going to start activating in
their head and then they're going to be
having to think about it and have
startle and have physiological reactions
until they can find a way to hit that
pause and shut it off again so they
still have you know impairments in other
ways but they go about their lives
they're not you know totally debilitated
if you have someone in that high range
the highest score is an 80 on the caps
miss hurt had a 28. if you have someone
in the higher range we have seen people
who are you know severely disabled
because of it but that's not the norm of
people who have on this moderate ptsd
and did you find functional impairment
with amber yes i did
now dr curry also said that
it is not within the scope of a
psychologist
to evaluate domestic violence do you
agree with that
of course i don't agree with that this
is what i do for a living day in day out
for 25 years we are specifically trained
to understand the profound impact that
trauma has on people's lives that's what
we do in the trauma division of the
american psychological association we
disseminate that knowledge and domestic
violence is one of those profound
traumas domestic violence is part of
state licensing boards that you can't
get licensed unless in some states
unless you take training on domestic
violence you can't renew your license
unless you get training on domestic
violence so people who have you know
specialized training in this area it is
you know holding upon them to accurately
assess for intimate partner violence and
sexual violence and it's more important
to assess for this sort of scientific
understanding of what domestic violence
is so you have to assess for the
physical violence the psychological
violence the surveillance the economic
the emotional abuse and the sexual
violence that is not gratuitous
all right next question okay um
now dr curry suggested that you made a
determination just based on personal
opinion and just on checklists and a
couple of tests that you misinterpreted
would you agree with that
i vehemently disagree with that as i
stated to you over 29 hours and 12
psychological tests and reviewing a slew
of documents in this case and most
importantly therapy records and
interviews collateral interviews with
therapists using all that data that is
what a a solid forensic methodological
exam looks like and then i made my
conclusions based on my clinical
education knowledge and training to come
up with a professional expert opinion
okay and just to remind you to make sure
we're reminded here you were qualified
in this court in this case as an expert
in forensic psychology and specifically
in domestic violence and in
the uh
no i just lost it uh
end in violence correct intimate and in
trauma correct
your honor mistakes the record
if you want to ask the question again
i probably should do that um
you were qualified
i gotta find my note
you were qualified as an expert in
forensic psychology with a specialty in
domestic violence and in trauma correct
correct okay and that was in this case
that's correct okay now do you still
hold the same opinions you did that you
gave the jury earlier
yes i do and do you still hold them
within a reasonable degree of
psychological probability and certainty
yes i do thank you all right
cross-examination yes senator can we
approach quickly
so
good morning dr hughes good morning mr
denison
last time you were here i believed that
you testified
that you had diagnosed
ms heard with ptsd
before you gave the gold standard
caps 5 test that's correct
right
and that diagnosis
is actually reflected in the first of
the
disclosures you put forward in this case
i believe the first disclosure was
february 2021 and at that point i had
done um 11 psychological tests that's
correct right
and
your disclosure reads ms heard's
responses on the pcl5
support a dsm-5 diagnosis
of
post-traumatic stress disorder
with an ideology ideology of intimate
partner violence she experienced my
former partner you remember writing that
that's correct
okay
you just testified
that you need to read the manual
right yes okay
can we put up 1311 as a demonstrative
any objection to 13 11 it is your honor
all right if you want to leave
you want to approach
thank you
i i don't see this in my document either
they're getting the right one up yeah
let's use 13 12. 13 12.
okay
and that
any objection to that demonstrative no
you're okay 13-12 can be published the
jury
dr hughes
do you recognize what the national
center for ptsd is
what it is yeah yes i do
and they publish
um
the ptsd checklist for dsm-5 that's
correct that what we've been calling the
pcl5 correct
all right and do you
uh are you familiar with the document
that's uh on your screen yes
what is it
uh it's
the instruction manual to how to
administer the pcl5 okay
i'd like to move for the admission of
1312.
any objection to 1312 coming into
evidence all right 13 12 and evidence
can we go to the second page
can we blow up
the second paragraph
on the right
that's
the pcl5 should not be used as a
standalone diagnostic tool
considering when considering a diagnosis
the clinician will still need to do
to use clinical interviewing skills and
a recommended structured interview
eg
the caps five
to determine a diagnosis correct that's
what the that's what the manual says
right in this manual also says that this
is a screening instrument so when you do
the clinical interviewing you absolutely
can determine diagnosis so the answer is
yes the manual says you you
still need
clinical interviewing skills which i use
let me finish my question
the pcl5 should not be used as a
standalone diagnostic tool
and they recommend using the caps 5 to
determine a diagnosis correct
it does say that yes yeah and you made
your diagnosis before
you did the caps 5.
i made my diagnosis doing clinical
interviewing and 11 other psychological
tests that supported diagnosis of ptsd
and symptomatology consistent with ptsd
okay
you said that we should read the manual
would you also agree with me that we
need to read the directions
on these tests
sure
okay
tom can you pull up
1309 as a demonstrative
yes sir
thank you
any objection of 1309 is a demonstration
may we approach okay
you know nine and publish the jury is
democracy
doctor do you
recognize
the
uh demonstrative that's in front of you
yes but i didn't put the red lines on
that no i did yes i know okay
um
so
this
what do you recognize this as
i recognize that we previously discussed
this and i told you that i oriented miss
her to a different time frame because
she was already out of the relationship
okay um maybe we should back it up a
little this is the cts two
that you administered as part of this
battery of tests that you
indicate you ought uh you did in
relationship to your diagnosis right
this is the conflict tactic scale too
and you'll agree with me
that this test
specifically asks
in front of every single question
how often did this happen in the past
year
correct and i oriented the individual to
not limit herself to the last year to
get an accurate assessment of the
violence and abuse that she experienced
in the relationship objection you're
unmoved to strike all right i'll move
strike the last part of the answer i
mean strike the last part of the answer
thank you
next question yeah and you know that at
the time
that you gave this test to miss heard
had been away from mr depp
for far longer than a year correct which
is why i oriented her to a different
time frame in answering the question
doctor yes or no of course okay you knew
she was gone for more than a year of
course all right
let's look at another one of these
[Music]
you talked about the danger assessment
test that's correct all right
thank you
any objection to the 1310
demonstrative okay
you published the jury
dr hughes
this is a blank form but this is the
dangerous assessment test that you
also gave to miss her correct
i didn't give it to her i filled it out
based on the data that was provided to
me oh so you you answer the questions
and then you filtered it it was somewhat
collaborative
okay
can we
blow up the second full paragraph
says using the calendar please mark the
approximate dates during the past year
when you were abused by your partner or
ex-partner
you didn't use any calendar did you
i did not use a calendar because she was
already out of the relationship as i
said these are static risk factors so
they don't change so i oriented to the
time of the
relationship
ma'am it's fair to say that ever this
examination
that you gave
specifically indicates that it's that
you were supposed to look over the past
year and you
that's the one no that's one
administration people use this
instrument
for if you're in an acute situation in a
relationship trying to get a better
assessment of the current behaviors we
can use it retrospectively like i just
stated and in homicides and looking back
about what are the serious risk factors
that were in this relationship i didn't
ask you about anything other than
don't the instructions
limit this test to the previous year
you can give this test not only on the
previous asking you about the
instructions but i'm telling you how the
test is administered in clinical
practice and forensic practice and
opposing counsel can come up and ask
questions about it i'm asking you about
the instructions and the instructions
say look over the past year
yeah on this yes that it says that and
you had actual knowledge when you gave
the test
that mr depp was gone way more than a
year before this test that is correct
right
all right let's look at more
instructions
can we look at 1247 which is already in
evidence
dr hughes
you recognize this one too right yes all
right this is the
what everybody calls the caps five
correct can we go the first page
let's blow up the instructions
standard administration and scoring of
the caps 5 are essential for producing
reliable and valid scores
and diagnostic decisions
correct correct
and you know you have to do this in a
standardized way because it is the first
instruction correct correct
can we go to the next to the
next page
one more oh wait
that's good
this is a page on scoring and we talked
about this last time yes you score these
tests
by
frequency and intensity correct
and you'll remember that
in every single instance that you were
asked to fill in the blank
about frequency
you failed to do so correct that's not
correct oh
you you filled in
any blank on this form with respect to
frequency
i filled in the frequency on the side of
the caps where i am actually scoring the
caps
no i asked you whether you filled in a
single blank on this form with respect
to frequency
is the answer to that yes or no i don't
know what you mean a single blank all
right let's let's page
down
let's keep going
all right let's
we'll stay at this page for a second
uh this is the very first
box you're asked to fill in as to
i think a fairly fundamental question
right what happened
we talked about this before mr denison i
had 88 pages of notes of what happened
it would have been redundant to put it
there you know that you are obligated to
produce this test in a way that other
people can meaningly review them
yes the people in this case who are
meaningfully reviewing them have my 88
pages of notes but you chose
to put absolutely nothing
in the box the standardized box that
said what happened
you don't have to put it in the box if
you have it somewhere else it's not
a standardized test if it's not a
research instrument that is used for
research if you're using it for a
clinical diagnostic purpose no you don't
if you have that data elsewhere okay
let's go another page or so
all right
let's do another one
all right let's look at item
4b4
and i asked you whether you filled in
the blank
about frequency
and there's a blank in many of these
items
that asks
number of times
you didn't fill a single one of them
into you
right because i filled them on the right
side of the instrument where i am
scoring it
and that is the way that you believe
that you
followed the instructions
of a standardized test yes correct no
further questions
all right redirects
very briefly
you use the term
static risk factor what did you mean by
that
static risk factors or risk factors that
don't change it's maybe um if you smoke
cigarettes you may have a risk of lung
cancer right that's a factor that
doesn't change you can look forward if
someone's smoking you can look fast if
someone's smoking so these
lethality risk factors are present
whether you're evaluating them in the
last year or five years ago
when you're trying to assess for
trauma related to the interpersonal
violence that we discussed
why is it important to get a time frame
in which the relationship was
in existence
well you want to see the amount of
trauma that the person experience the
longer that they're in a relationship
you have more successive trauma and one
of the things that we know from the
research is more trauma is not better so
the more successive traumas that you
have the greater likelihood that
somebody's going to have psychological
consequences and symptomatology as a
result and therefore you need to get it
within the relationship objection
leading
and so how does that
relate to needing to get the time frame
in the relationship well you need to
understand the
when you're under when you're trying to
evaluate the impact of something you
won't have to understand what happened
to the person and that's sort of the
core and the basis of of trauma-informed
care and of trauma diagnosis you have to
understand you know the traumatic event
and how it transpired and how it played
out for that individual so that you can
better assess for the symptomatology
that's falling from it
you said you had 88 pages of notes what
were in your 88 and without going into
the specifics can you just describe what
was included in the 88 pages of notes um
in the 88 pages were um
many of the documented incidents of
intimate friends objection your honor
she's just describing it that came up he
said you didn't fill those in the boxes
she said it was in my 88 pages i'm just
saying what was in your 88 pages
i'm not asking her to give each of the
specific events she can describe the
summary of it
can we come up okay
what is the difference between
clinical scoring and clinical evaluation
and research evaluation with respect to
the caps 5 and the other tests
and compound
sustained
you're on when it's compounded because
it might be confusing to the jury
sustained next question okay
can you explain to the jury what the
difference is between clinical scoring
and evaluation on a test and research
infection your honor compound
overruled gun sure so the the pcl and
the caps fiber are frequently used in
research and when they're used in
research that means the document stands
alone they don't have 88 pages of notes
to help understand the background of the
trauma and what the person has
experienced and why those boxes may be
relevant in research is because you know
back in the day when i was a research
assistant i had to input that into the
computer and then they would maybe look
at some of that data for the research
study so that becomes very important in
research
all right thank you i've got further
questions all right thank you doctor you
could have seen the courtroom where
you're free to go okay thank you very
much all right ladies and gentlemen
let's go ahead and take our afternoon
recess i mean sorry our morning recess
i'll just take our 15 minute recess do
not discuss the case with anybody and
don't do any outside research okay
all right why don't we just come back at
1105 then
are you ready for the jury
yes yes sure
[ __ ]
do
all right thank you ladies and gentlemen
maybe seated are your next
witness your honor defendant calls amber
hurt all right i heard if you come to
the stand please
yes ma'am
water
thank you ma'am just a reminder you're
still under oath okay of course your
honor thank you thank you all right your
question
amber just to orient you and the jury at
this time we are in the rebuttal to your
counter claim against mr depp so i'm
gonna confine my questions to that okay
all right
how have you suffered publicly as a
result of the depth waldman statements
objection speculation
overrule
i am
harassed
humiliated
threatened
every single day
even just walking into this courtroom
sitting here
in front of the world
having the worst parts of my life
things i've lived through used to
humiliate me
people want to kill me
and they tell me so
every day
people want to put my baby in the
microwave
and they tell me that
johnny
threatened
promised
promised me
that if i ever left him he'd make me
think of him
every single day
that i lived
objection your honor non-responsive
all right i'll sustain the objection as
to that if you want to ask the question
amber
how did mr depp's
statements and threats to you that you
were discussing
how do those continue to manifest
themselves today
in the harassment and the humiliation
the campaign against me that's echoed
every single day
on social media and now
in front of cameras in this room
every single day i have to relive the
trauma
my hands shake i wake up screaming i
have to live with the trauma and the
damage done to me
my friends have to live with a set of
unspoken rules about how to not scare me
objection hearsay
[Music]
yes sir unspoken rules
about how to not touch me
not to surprise me
my intimate partners
have rules about how they can deal with
me how they can touch me
i have rules for doctors medical
professionals i see gynecologists i see
i live my life
with these sets of rules that i have to
follow my friends have to follow for me
not to have a panic attack or a
triggering event
where i relive the trauma even if i'm
training to do my movie for instance i'm
training for aquaman
a combat scene and a trigger happens i
have a meltdown
and have to deal with that the the crew
i work with have to deal with that
because of the damage i walk around with
every single day
from what i've lived through
from what i've survived i'm not sitting
in this courtroom snickering
i'm not sitting in this courtroom
laughing smiling making snide jokes i'm
not
this is horrible
this is painful
and this is humiliating for any human
being to go through
and perhaps it's easy to forget that but
i'm a human being
and even though johnny promised that i
deserved this and promised you do this i
don't deserve this
i want to move on
the statements
the attacks on me the campaign
that
that johnny has elicited millions of
people
to do on his behalf when he himself
foundation
torturing speculation
i'll sustain the objection next question
amber
how the depth waldman statements
impacted
your ability to do charitable work
you know
i would
the only reason that
people like dr kirby can sit up here on
the stand and say i'm high functioning
and i do things like have hobbies
and have interests
your honor mr depp gave long-winded
responses
it's because i found a solution to that
pain
i woke up every morning
with panic attacks and
trauma until i realized i could do
something with it
so to answer your question ben it's i
i was able to turn the things that i've
lived through my pain my life
experiences into work into action into
providing a voice for other people
i'm not a saint i'm not trying to
present myself as one as you all know
but i
selfishly found
relief
in being able to use what i've lived
through
to advocate for others
to bring light to these issues to give a
voice to people who don't have the voice
and the platform that i have
and while i would not wish this
situation on my worst enemy
if it gives a voice to someone who
doesn't have it
but i now as i stand here today can't
have a career i can't even have people
associate with me because of the threats
and the attacks that they have to endure
actually being responsive and i can't
humanity will sustain the objection
[Music]
amber other than the threats that you've
described what other threats have you
endured since the debt waldman
statements were made
i receive
hundreds
of death threats
regularly if not daily thousands since
this trial has started people mocking
mocking
my testimony about being assaulted
making fun of my objection relevance
non-responsive
you can continue
it's been
agonizing
agonizing
painful
and most humiliating
thing i've ever had to go through
oh no one ever has to go through
something like this
i just want johnny to leave me alone i
just want him to leave me alone
i've said that
for years now and i thought he would
after
non-responsive
all right i'll sustain objection next
question
what do you hope to reclaim
after this is over
protecting the secret that i
did for as long as i did
has taken enough of my voice
johnny has taken enough of my voice
i have the right
to tell my story i have the right to say
what happened to me i feel right to my
voice in my name
he took it long enough
i have a right as an american
to talk about what happened to me to own
my story and my truth
i have that right
i hope to get my voice back
it's all i want
and i've said that from day one
thank you amber i don't have anything
else all right cross-examination
actually your honor may we approach yes
so
miss her you just testified that this
case has been very hard for you so let's
talk about that and why
all right
your lies have been exposed to the world
multiple times right
i've been lied about anything i've been
here to say
you sat here and told this jury that the
events in hicksville started with mr
depp getting really upset about a woman
leaning on you is that correct
yes that's effectively what happened
yeah you testified that he actually
grabbed that woman's wrist and twisted
it right
and told her
that he could effectively break her
wrist by saying he knew how many pounds
of pressure asking or how many pounds of
pressure it took to break the human
wrist but your own witness your former
best friend rocky pennington she didn't
corroborate that did she
i'm not quite sure what part of that
night she saw there were a lot of people
there
she didn't testify that mr depp rap
grabbed anyone's wrist in hicksville
again i don't know what rocky saw there
were a lot of people there that night
you testified that once you brought mr
depp back to your trailer he trashed it
correct that is correct
and the manager of the hicksville
trailer park was furious that johnny had
wrecked the whole thing do you remember
that testimony that's correct well we
heard from that manager of the
hicksville trailer park morgan knight on
monday didn't we
i'm not quite sure who that guy was or
if he had any involvement in this i know
a lot of people have come out of the
woodwork to be
involved
so you're accusing mr knight of
testifying
and committing perjury i'm not accusing
anyone i just don't recognize that man
you heard mr knight testify that it was
actually you who was upset with mr depp
spending time away from him isn't that
correct
how would he know he wasn't there
you heard mr knight testify that it was
actually you who was yelling at mr dub
again
i've heard a lot of people say a lot of
things to be involved in the johnny depp
show but
he wasn't there
he doesn't know and he certainly doesn't
know what happened behind closed doors
like most people so you're calling mr
knight a liar
i am saying he wasn't there and what he
testified to doesn't match what i know
happened
but i don't fault him he wasn't there so
how would he know
he testified he was there misheard did
you hear that that's his testimony yes
so you're calling him a liar
i'm just saying he wasn't there
you heard mr knight testify that the
trailer wasn't trashed and that's why
you're calling him a liar
he testified that a light fixture was
broken similar to the way that yes other
than a light fixture that was the only
thing
the only thing that was broken in the
trailer according to mr knight was a
light fixture yes or no i realized that
he summed it up by saying a light
fixture was broken just the way his
security guard summed up him trashing my
closet as being ready i'm going to move
to strike everything after he summed it
up that it was a light fixture
as non-responsive answer the question
the security guard testimony i'll allow
it go ahead
mr knight also testified that he charged
mr deb only 62 dollars for the damage
light fixture you heard that correct i
did
in hicksville you were the only one that
was jealous that mr def was spending
time from other people isn't that
correct mr that is incorrect in
hicksville you were the one who was
upset that mr depp wasn't giving you
enough attention
incorrect
again it's heard you told this jury that
you had no idea the press was going to
be at the courthouse when you got your
tro on may 27th 2016. do you remember
that testimony
uh i said i did not have anything to do
with it yes
no my question again
you told this jury
that you had no idea that the press was
going to be outside after you got the ex
party tro on may 27 2016. do you
remember that testimony i apologize i
must have misunderstood miss vasquez um
i actually had no idea whether they were
going to be there or not when i walked
into the courtroom that day it was
completely quiet still empty
even though i had given johnny's team
notice that i was fighting
and your honor i would also ask that you
instruct the witness to please stop
talking once i lodge an objection your
honor she's trying to answer the
question as best she can and ms vasquez
is misrepresenting to her what she
testified to well i'll strike the last
part is non-responsive just if you guys
answer the questions asked okay thank
you
in fact you testified that you were
quote shocked when you saw press when
you were leaving the courthouse yes yes
you weren't shocked at all though were
you
uh incorrect it was you knew the press
would be at the courthouse right miss
herd
no
well you did bring your publicist to the
courthouse with you on may 27 2016
didn't you i sure did i'm a public
figure i brought my publicist in case
it blew up in case you actually had
alerted tmz that you would be filing a
tiara against mr depp that very day
didn't you no i didn't one day you
didn't bother to wear makeup to cover up
the mark on your face i did not call tmz
or any other news source or paparazzi
source no one
i never did testimony from former tmz
employee morgan tremaine yesterday
correct did i hear his testimony yes yes
i was here yes and you heard mr
tremaine's testimony that he knew to
dispatch the paparazzi to the courthouse
on may 27th right i heard him say that
he knew that yes yeah and that he
dispatched paparazzi to the courthouse
to capture a picture of an alleged
bruise on the right side of your face do
you remember him saying that i remember
him saying that
that information must have come from
your team right ms heard absolutely not
why would i want that what actual
survivor of domestic violence wants that
now the video of mr depp beating up some
kitchen cabinets you admit that you took
that video correct
yes i did
and you acknowledged that the video was
released online the day before you were
deposed in connection with your divorce
from mr depp in august of 2016. right i
believe it was yes but you testified
that you had absolutely nothing to do
with the video's release right
absolutely not
and you testified that you learned about
it when you landed after flying into la
do you remember that testimony upon
touchdown is when i was alerted to the
videos you heard mr tremaine testify
that this about this video as well
yesterday didn't you yes i did and you
heard mr tremaine testify that tmz
received the cabinet video the same day
you landed at lax yes
i don't know if that i don't know if
that's what his testimony was i'm sorry
you heard mr tomaine testify that the
cabinet video was posted
15 minutes after tmz received it yes
that's what i heard him say and that
this could only have been possible if
the video was received directly from the
source yes i heard him say that i don't
know if that's true or if that's
possible because it didn't come from me
i was flying tremaine so
i know that's incorrect is what i mean
to say
another liar on the stand i just know
that that's incorrect all right and you
heard mr tremaine testify that tmz owns
the copyright to the cabinet video right
that's news to me the cabinet video you
filmed of your then husband yes
the copyright ownership of that is news
to me i learned that yesterday it's the
cabinet video that you captured of your
then husband yes that is correct i did
capture that video and yes
my husband the same cabinet video that
was released the night before you were
deposed in your divorce yes that's
correct
you must have also heard mr tumain
testify that the version of the cabinet
video that tmz received was incomplete
compared to the video the jury saw in
this trial did you hear that
the video that the jury that you have
seen is complete
right but the one tmz got the day before
your deposition in the divorce was
incomplete i don't know i haven't seen
it he testified that at the beginning
portion of the video where you set up
the camera that wasn't included in the
video that tmc received i don't know
what video teams i'm talking about mr
tremaine's testimony was heard let's
just ask
his testimony no i'm asking you if you
recall hearing him say those words to
this jury
i heard his testimony we all did and he
testified at the end of the video where
you can see be seen smirking
i know you testified earlier that you
haven't been smirking in this trial but
you sure were caught on camera smirking
in that video i disagree with that not
inc was also not included in the tmz
video everyone can watch that video and
you can determine whether you think it's
funny to me or not that's because the
video came from you right miss heard
no it did not you had a video portion
you edited out the portions that made
you look bad before sending it to tmc
you were very wrong about that so i
wanted to leave information i could have
done it in a more effective way a lot
sooner and a lot more because i was
leaving
this evidence if i wanted to leak it i
could have done a lot more with it
i thought you testified earlier in this
trial that you didn't know how to leak
things i don't
you edited that video before you gave it
to tmz so that only mr depp would look
bad yes that's absurd
right in the middle of your divorce
proceedings
again you're very wrong
i'd like to show you
a picture from that's already admitted
into evidence it's defendants exhibit
799
this is you at the courthouse on may 27
2016 when you got your domestic violence
restraining order against mr depp right
it is and next to you is a woman named
jody gottlieb right yes jody gottlieb is
your publicist and dear friend
now i'd like to show you what's been
marked as plaintiff's exhibit 1316.
this is a picture of you and your friend
rocky pennington right that is correct
your honor i'd like to move to admit
this photograph any objection to 1316.
no your honor all right 13 16 in
evidence you can publish the journey
this is a picture of you on may 28 2016
right miss hurd i don't know when this
was taken
this is the day after you obtained the
domestic violence restraining order
against mr depp right
i have no idea when this image was taken
i did not take it there's no bruise on
your face in this picture is there again
i don't know when this was taken and
also i'm outside i was obviously wearing
makeup i have no idea when this was
taken so i have no idea if i can speak
for special recollections you can
refresh your recollection about when
this picture was taken um can we please
pull up plaintiff's exhibit 1315 just
for the witness
this is an article dated may 30th 2016
right miss heard
that's what it says yes
and this article contains the same
photograph of you miss pennington we
were just looking at yes
yes i see that and the article is
entitled amber heard smiles as she puts
arm around friend one day after getting
restraining order against johnny depp
is that what the title says
i know that's what the title says yes
your honor i'm going to move to admit
and publish the article with everything
but the headline and date and the photo
redacted
objection your honor that's inconsistent
from the way you treated all of these
i'll sustain the objection all right
next question
let's take a look at picture plaintiff's
exhibit 1317.
this is also a picture of you and miss
pennington on may 28 2016 isn't it i
don't know when this photo was taken but
it looks like the same outing as the
picture prior your honor i'm going to
move to admit and publish plaintiff's
exhibit 1317 any objection no you got it
1317 in evidence you can publish
there's no bruise on your face in this
picture either right
i disagree uh if it is
taken when you represent it was taken
then obviously there's a bruise on my
face it's covered by makeup as per usual
let's zoom out of that picture for a
moment please thanks tom
that's josh drew in this picture right
yes that's correct miss pennington that
is correct
in there too
mr pennington submitted a sworn
statement on your behalf in support of
your domestic violence restraining order
didn't she
i believe she did yes mr drew also
submitted a statement in support of your
domestic violence restraining order
i believe they both did yes
that's right i'd like to show you
defendants exhibit 512 which is already
in evidence
you've seen this photograph before right
i have on the second day of your direct
testimony you testified that this was
taken in the downstairs of the main
apartment on december 15 2015. do you
recall that testimony
yes i believe so
so it's your testimony that defendants
exhibit 512 reflects damage to penthouse
5 that occurred during the december 15
2015 incident yes
i'm not quite sure
from what incident this is when i see
this photo in a in a vacuum without
context
let's give you that context
can we please
i could have day 16 trial testimony
all right
could you please turn first to page
four five eight five
specifically on starting on line 16
where it says let's talk about december
15th 2015. i'm you said four five eight
oh four i'm on four four eight five
sorry you said four five eight five four
five eight five are done line sixteen
so
line 16 where it says let's talk about
december 15 2015. do you see that
yes
and then do you see that your testimony
about december 15 2015 follows
let's see it's just the first line or
two
yes okay now i'd like you to turn to
page 4603
starting at line 12
4603
starting at line 12 and going on to page
4604 line four
okay
and do you see that you testify that
defendants exhibit 512 which is on the
screen yes is a picture of the
downstairs of the main apartment that's
correct and the main apartment is
penthouse 5 in the eastern columbia
building right
no the well
depends on what the main apartment's
penthouse 3 generally when we say main
apartment penthouse 5 was where you had
your closet
the downstairs was kind of like a had
some of my painting studio set up and a
reception area upstairs was the closet
mezzanine
office was in between all right so it's
your testimony that defendants exhibit
512 reflects damage to the penthouse
penthouse 5 that occurred during the
december 15 2015 incident right i'm just
not sure from which incident this is a
picture of since i'm only looking at
even though our counselor
was asking you questions about december
15 2015 and then admitted this test this
picture into evidence i again in
relation to that incident sorry go ahead
in relation to that incident on december
15 2015.
this exhibit defendant's exhibit you are
the defendant
number 512 was admitted into evidence in
this court you testified that this was
the result of damage that occurred on
december 15 2015. yes or no
i just need to orient myself because i'm
just looking at a picture of a partial
picture of it you didn't just look at a
picture
you looked at your testimony i you
pointed me towards the page and then
asked me a question i haven't actually
reviewed it i don't know if this was
submitted in relation to that incident
let's pull up
let's actually leave up defendants 512
and please pull up defendants exhibit
725
which is already in evidence
and redacted form your honor all right
thank you you can publish just side by
side
you've seen this photograph as well
right i have
on the third day of your direct
testimony you testified that this
photograph reflected spilled wine in
penthouse 5 on may 21st 2016. didn't you
again i don't know because i'm looking
at a partial picture of a floor so
unless you've removed the metadata
you've covered up we could then tell if
you i didn't cover it up you're on could
we un-reduce
that's how it's in evidence that's how
it's in evidence next question well the
metadata next to it is so this is heard
there is no question pending and i would
appreciate it if you wouldn't be making
argument to the jury sorry i thought you
would ask me about it no i didn't ask
you about anything
let's look at your direct testimony from
the third day
yes ma'am
thank you
thank
you let's turn to page four seven five
zero
in day 17 transcript
uh sorry four seven five zero
specifically line 16.
do you see where mrs bradenhoff asked
you to describe for the jury what took
place on may 21st 2016. i see that
and you see that your testimony
is reflected about may 21 2015
yes that follows okay yes
now let's turn to page 4804
at line 14.
four eight zero four
starting at line fourteen yes
through four eight zero five line four
going to what line
line 4 at 4805
do you see that you're testifying that
defendant's exhibit 725 which is
reflected on the right side reflects
spilled wine on the floor in penthouse
5. that's correct okay and defendants
exhibit 512 and 725 seem to be different
versions of the same picture don't they
that's correct okay so which is it which
one was taken on december 15th 2015
or may 24th first 2016.
if you remove the redact metadata you
can find out
it's right there or if you're telling
the truth you would know
recognize a portion of a of spilled wine
on a floor and i'm supposed to know off
the top of my head when you've lived
through five years of this stuff i don't
think so that's not how that works okay
thank you tom
miss heard at the beginning of your
cross-examination last yes
all right ladies and gentlemen the
gallery i would ask that there would be
no words or no phrases no words
no sounds at all coming from you if i
hear one more sound i will clear the
gallery and we will continue this
testimony without anybody in the
courtroom understood good all right your
next question
ms heard at the beginning of your
cross-examination last week i showed you
an audio where you told mr depp to tell
the jury
tell the judge tell the world that he is
a victim of domestic abuse do you
remember that that's correct you
testified you found it hard to believe
that mr depp would tell the world that
he's a victim of domestic abuse
didn't you
i said i find it hard to believe that he
would do that knowing that he himself
had beat me up for five years but he has
told the world that he's your victim of
domestic abuse hasn't he
well he started to say that only
recently he didn't make that claim up
until very recently so when we signed
our divorce agreement and we signed a
statement saying that neither party had
ever said false claims for financial
gain
it was relevant and important to me
because i was the only one making the
accusations i was the only one making
those claims he wasn't doing that at the
time and he signed his name to it
you didn't expect as many people to show
up and testify on his behalf that did
did you
incorrect
when you told this jury under oath that
you never assaulted
actually
um when you told this jury under oath
that you punched mr depp because you
thought of mr deb pushing kate moss down
the stairs you didn't expect miss moss
to agree to testify that that never
happened did you incorrect i know how
many people will come out of the
woodwork to be in support of johnny so
you think this mom needs to come out of
the woodwork to testify for mr depp
everybody who was around in the 90s and
the early aughts knew that rumor i had
heard that rumor from multiple people of
course that's what flashed through my
head when my violent husband not only
swung for me but all of a sudden swung
for my sister
of course i thought of that i did not
expect her to show up or not expect her
to show up it didn't matter it doesn't
change what i believed at the time when
we were on the stairs and i thought he
was going to kill my sister by pushing
her down the stairs
you told this jury under oath and mr
depp was aggressive and trashed a
trailer in hicksville you didn't expect
the manager of the hicksville property
morgan knight to come forward and
testify that that wasn't true did you
incorrect i've already been through
trials with this man i know how many
people will come out in support of him
when you told this jury under oath that
you had no idea that the paparazzi would
be at the courthouse on may 27 2016 you
didn't expect a tmz employee to show up
to testify that tmz had been alerted
that you would be at the courthouse and
knew exactly which side of your face to
take a picture of did you
i know how many people will come out and
say whatever for him that's his power
that's why i wrote the op-ed is i was
speaking to that phenomenon how many
people will come out in support of him
and will fall to his power he is a very
powerful man and people love carrying
favor with powerful men and i know that
firsthand jail time for committing
perjury
excuse me
i didn't i didn't hear your question
excuse me question
ms vasquez if you do
please just repeat the question i didn't
hear you curry favor and commit perjury
in this courtroom
i have a powerful man i have seen people
do this time and time again
that's why i wrote the op-ed you didn't
expect ben king the house manager in
australia to show up from england he
flew from england to testify that mr
duff's fingertip was found exactly where
he said it would be did you
i have never heard johnny testify to
knowing where his finger was or really
frankly
making a claim that he knew where it was
when it was found
i've never heard johnny claim that you
didn't expect him johnny has never heard
he said that it's
you didn't expect keenan wyatt mr
death's longtime sound technician to
show up and testify that mr depp is not
being fed lines through his ear pieces
but instead music did you
not that it matters much but of course
of course i did i i know how his
employees treat him so you probably his
team treats him of course i expected
that okay so you probably expected
either bruce to come and testify for mr
deb right
um i'm not sure i thought about that
yeah but you didn't expect mr baroosh to
weep
to weep for mr depp
after what you've put him through and so
many others with your life i relate to i
relate to isaac because he and i are the
only ones who pride on this stand
nothing all right
redirect
thank you your honor miss heard if mr
baroosh felt misled who misled him
johnny and i don't blame him i don't
blame him from crying this is horrible
miss vasquez has suggested that you
faked bruises on your face is that true
absolutely not i didn't need to
did you ever fake an injury caused by mr
debt
no
is any of the evidence of your injuries
that has been put to the jury in this
trial fake
no absolutely not
and to the extent that there may be some
confusion over when a picture of spilled
wine was taken why might that be
objection lack of foundation overrule
because there's so many incidents of
violence there are so there's so many
pictures there's so much evidence most
people don't have this kind of evidence
for years five
years and when i was saying that to
johnny on the phone in that recording i
was saying for years this has been going
on and i have pictures we have text we
have everything
normally you don't get this amount of
evidence that's what i was pointing out
to johnny would be crazy to try to
challenge this in this way
it's crazy it's easy to to not know the
context of a picture of spilled wine
because there are so many more important
details pictures and also
so much i didn't photograph so much i
didn't have the presence it's actually
non-responsive i'll sustain the
objection next question did mr depp
abuse you physically
yes
verbally
yes
emotionally yes
psychologically
yes
how did the threats
that mr depp made against you
individually years ago
resemble what you have endured as a
result of the debt waldman statements
beyond the scope across your honor oh
world
johnny
promised me
promised me
he would ruin me
that he'd ruin my career
he'd take my life from me death was the
only way out and if i got out this is
what he'd do to me he'd make me think of
him every single day he promised me
global humiliation you saw those texts
he
what he couldn't do
the work of one individual meaning
johnny when he was
inviting a disgruntled employee over for
a spot a purple to fix my flabby ass up
that revenge that he sought back then
was just what he could do as an
individual calling the studio to get me
fired trying to block him
objection on her lack of foundation
speculation here
non-responsive i'll sustain us to
non-response
ms heard how did those
things that you just testified to that
mr depp did how did those resemble what
happened to you after the dep waldman
counter claim statements were made
well those are your honor lack of
foundation
she's
overruled thank you thank you your honor
those are just an echo
of what
i'm living through today it's like what
i'm living in right now what you see in
this courtroom is an echo this courtroom
and the other courtroom he dragged me
into to do the same thing again
that's just an echo of the violence and
the abuse that i suffered within our
relationship
the campaigns to have me fired that
blocking me to try to ruin my career the
threats he's made to humiliate me
globally
are being lived out in real time in
front of you ladies and gentlemen for
the past six weeks and for the whole
world since our cameras here
no further questions thank you so much
amber all right i'm sorry you can have a
seat next to your attorneys
if i can have the attorney's approach
all right your next witness your honor
the counter claimant amber heard rests
all right thank you man
all right ladies and gentlemen you have
heard all the evidence you're going to
hear in this matter what i propose doing
is to go ahead and give you the rest of
the afternoon off so you can have a good
restful afternoon and evening and we
will do closing arguments tomorrow
morning at 9 a.m and then the case will
be submitted to you for deliberations
just to give you a little logistics of
how that will go
tomorrow
i won't give you a time limit as far as
how long you can deliberate in the
afternoon into the evening
i will tell you within reason i will
tell you i do not serve dinner so keep
that in mind okay you will not be
deliberating on saturday or sunday or
monday because monday is a holiday i
would like to have you back here tuesday
morning
at least by nine o'clock if you want to
come earlier that's up to you you can
decide as a group if you want to come
earlier than nine o'clock but you have
to be here at least by nine o'clock just
to resume your deliberations again
and again on tuesday night and if you
have to go to wednesday or thursday that
the time that when you take your breaks
is up to you as long as you take them uh
together as far as not having any
deliberations unless all of the jurors
are in the room at the same time when
you take your lunch is up to you and
then again in the evening within reason
i'll let you go as long as you'd like to
go okay
so have a good evening and we'll see you
tomorrow morning okay do not discuss the
case with anybody don't do any outside
research
all right
we'll go ahead and take a
a modified lunch recess just till 12 50.
we'll come back at 12 50. we just have a
few jury instructions left we have to do
make sure we get the verdict form taken
care of i want you to review the laptop
that we have mocked up and make sure
everybody agrees what's on it
and also i want you to look through all
your exhibits and make sure we're on the
same page before you leave i'll make
sure you have copies of the jury
instructions in the order that i'm going
to read them and you should be able to
prepare for your closing arguments for
tomorrow okay all right we'll see at 12
50 then
you